i take you now to the year 1991.
nina you're
a bouncing baby girl
yeah i've won
brian you have just received your first
copy of aarp magazine
brian no longer has to pay to ride the
public bus
[Laughter]
today we're going to talk about the
marvel teams we want to see in the
marvel cinematic universe there are a
lot of teams to choose from in marvel
comics and we wrote about a lot of them
over on looper.com and our marvel teams
you want to see in the mcu article
i'm gonna
mention
some of the ones that i know of that i
definitely would love to see in the mcu
and the first one here is the young
avengers which we all know
they seem to be building
right like can we all agree that the
young avengers are basically like one
phase away from being announced they're
just going to wait it's definitely going
to happen there's no
they're going to wait for willy and
billy to get a little older and yes i
know it's tommy and billy but i like
willie and billy bell better
i think fantastic
i think that's what they should have
been named
willy and billy
you should tell wanda that for sure
she'll take it well
it's the same name just
with one as a nickname and then one is
saying i don't think she handles
criticism particularly well so i tried
carefully oh yeah that's a good point
never mind so the young avengers came
out in i'd say like the mid-2000s
sort of as marvel's riff on um
teen titans in this interesting way
for the longest time the x-men and the
teen titans were kind of corollaries
between marvel and dc where there was a
lot of soap opera aspects a lot of you
know younger characters interacting with
some older characters being placed in
tough situations and the x-men started
out as a school so a lot of the
characters kind of have that kind of
feed in from the young the young
superhero game to the older superhero
game so x-men and teen titans were how
they kind of lined up but then uh marvel
went and created this this book called
the young avengers that had
very like pretty much
altogether brand new versions younger
versions of
established avengers characters and it
was really cool so you have kate bishop
who's going to be in the new hawkeye
show
you had speed and wiccan who are the
aforementioned william billy hulkling
who's a skrull we talked about this very
recently in a different video
and patriot i think was his name who was
elijah bradley's grandson yeah and iron
lad who is a young version of kang from
the future to our present trying to
change his own villainous future so
there was a real a lot of really cool
stuff that they did that was that was a
fun kind of
marvel
filtered version of teen titans that was
interesting and i think that it went on
for much longer than i continued to read
so i would be
curious to see that
show up so that was one of them
another one was the future foundation
which is kind of a riff on the fantastic
four getting weirder and bigger with
lots of
strange characters i know tom you have
some thoughts about the future
foundation do you i love the future
foundation i think they're fantastic
they were terrific
yeah
no they were great yeah it was it was
sort of what like late 2000s early 2010s
and uh
they
decided to expand the fantastic four
universe a little bit they had this
whole skyscraper and so right why not
use it to start educating and creating a
better tomorrow that was the idea it was
nice it was optimistic sci-fi and it's
yeah a bunch of women that's rare and a
bunch of other weirdos to uh yeah
to try and turn them into better weirdos
again sort of like a riff a riff on the
x-men teen titans thing where it's a lot
of superpower characters but now they're
in this
school of the future foundation and
they're learning to be better super
weirdos this is exactly what you said
there was uh the fantastic four
spider-man was in there for a little
while you got sue and reed richards two
super powered kids
valeria richards in particular being
super duper smart and then you had what
was it like a clone of the thinker yeah
wasn't there
wizard the wizard that was it sorry
yeah and uh and the wizard isn't a
wizard he's he's just a science bad guy
he's basically the leader with a smaller
head yeah yeah
and the leader is just the hulk but
brains instead of muscles see we're like
we're breaking down all the various ways
in which marvel takes a concept and says
what if what if hulkbook brains accept
muscles you know right like what if
right how can we take one idea and make
five different permutations out of it
right or twenty exactly
right like they say what what if
spider-man but bad and and and gooey and
you get venom and then you say what if
venom but red and then you get carnage
and then
yeah no
that's exactly right electric booga goo
is that anything
it's something not yet but it'll get
there
okay yeah we can workshop it so yeah
future foundation's a really fun one and
so obviously we'd have to wait until
fantastic four are introduced for
anything resembling the future
foundation to happen but
what a cool modern take on the fantastic
four story right because like back in
the 60s the fantastic four is hey these
four people stole a rocket ship went
into space and turned super and now it's
more like these four superheroes who do
crazy adventures are now kind of trying
to make it so that all these other
strange beings in the world are
being geared towards a more positive
future putting some great responsibility
to that great power that's right exactly
the marvel way um but the one that i was
really drawn to and wanted to talk about
is called next wave agents of hate
um
so i read this back when it came out and
i think it was a two
very very short two-volume series
basically they put out two collections
that i own that are
right here
just to
there you go
backwards there you go
there so i reread them this morning i
reread the first one i should say and uh
it's a lot goofier than i remember but
it was always so basically the premise
here is that it's just kind of like
what if shield
was extremely evil and dumb
and instead of instead of flying around
in a flying aircraft carrier they flew
around in a flying submarine and what if
instead of having a super team like the
avengers
they had a different super team that
went rogue because they found out that
they were evil and dumb
so that's next wave so it's it's five
superheroes photon monica rambo who we
met in
uh captain marvel the first captain
marvel movie and then in one division
machine man who is
a robot um
elsa bloodstone who's the daughter of an
older
marvel character named
wolfgang bloodstone i don't remember his
first name something bloodstone and he
fought wolfgang sounds good i'll accept
that it might be wolfgang i'm sure let's
put it right right here what his actual
name is his name is this
bloodhound gang
right um so
and then who else is in that boom boom
from x-force whose power was to make
things explode
and there was one more oh the captain
this is the only brand new character um
his name was captain and then it had a
bunch of
um
like asterisks for a curse word and so
they're just cool risque yeah yes it was
very edgy i'm imagining all the
possibilities that that could be
so
what's interesting what's interesting
about this book is that it's basically
just kind of this deconstruction of
superheroes generally it's it's written
by uh warren ellis and illustrated by
stuart imminent and so the art is really
really great it's really dynamic and
exciting
the writing is really stripped back it's
very catch phrase-y it's very
tongue-in-cheek um it doesn't read as
well today as i remember it
when did it come out oh seven
so it's been a while it's been a minute
okay but
i can see this coming to the mcu in an
interesting way
because you've already got
um
you've already got photon and then the
rest of the characters you could just
introduce however the heck you want and
you could just kind of make it more of a
you know
agents of shield with a higher budget um
not taking things too seriously being
funny so guardians of the galaxy on
earth let's just call it guardians of
the galaxy what on planet earth and
that's basically what it is they yeah
it's you know the concept's a little too
high like it can't be a one-to-one
translation from the comic book to the
mcu you'd have to do a lot of adaptation
the tone
of the book doesn't fit like even the
rest of the marvel universe it takes
place in its own little
thing i mean just as an example the
first issue starts in a town called
abscess iowa
nice
like it's just like very it's very it's
intentionally goofy
and silly
and it's not meant to be taken very
seriously so again it wouldn't fit super
well in the mcu but i love the idea of
a super powered group of of of people
you know screwing up and taking down
monsters like in the first issue they
fight fin fang foom who's this great
character from the 60s who's just a
giant dragon and purple underpants
perfect so yeah next wave agents of hate
instead of agents of shield
i'm just imagining the poster is that
arrest development running gag of the
magicians alliance where it's like
they're all posing and it says we demand
to be taken seriously
exactly and there's there's your movie
poster just built in
i think i think there's room for it in
the mcu
i think that it would have to skew a
little goofier than a lot of the rest of
it
but clearly marvel's ready to do things
like that like the episode of what if
was it it was basically like
it was like i know it's animated already
but this was the first episode of what
if that was basically a cartoon where
like captain marvel and thor fight
because thor is just like throwing a
party that's going to destroy the earth
so they're sharing each other to
different countries and you can see the
name of the country when you zoom out to
see the planet earth it was very very
goofy so i'm thinking this is a long
walk to say i think they could do it
sure i don't see why not
thank you for indulging me in this long
monologue earlier you're welcome i hope
people are still watching i somehow
doubt it
oh bro but nina nino what's what super
team do you think uh you'd like to see
in the mcu
uh bloodhound gang obviously
i think they'd be a great fit no i have
a real pick i promise um i so i um was
also looking at the article on
looper.com and uh i
i mean this is gonna be very on brand
for me
so everyone act really surprised when i
picked this i picked the lady liberators
um
and uh it was actually pretty
interesting to do some research on this
because uh the first there have been two
team ups for the lady liberators and the
first one was in 19 in the 1970s which
is right when the second iteration of
the equal rights amendment was being
championed by
you know women's lib movements and stuff
like that if you watched um
the fx show mrs america from last year
you know all about that and i feel like
four people have and one of them is me
but mcu star kate blanchett was in it so
right so anyway basically in the first
one uh a woman that appears to be
valkyrie and looks like valkyrie she
assembles a group that includes let's
see it has wasp black widow scarlet
witch and medusa when we have not seen
or am i correct that we've not seen
medusa not in the big screen certainly
but has she been in any
smaller spin-off character she was
things yeah she was in the inhumans show
okay that's what imax run it was on the
big screen okay that's you were unlucky
enough wild technicalities
okay let me ask a differently phrased
question has medusa been in the any
phases official ones of the marvel
cinematic universe yet i mean
technically inhumans is part of the mcu
but no one has ever mentioned it yeah so
i'm gonna give it to you and say no
well i mean it doesn't really
it has no bearing on whether or not the
lady liberators could be in it if she's
been in the mcu already or not i just i
haven't seen inhumans so i haven't
experienced medusa so basically they
team up
yeah and so basically
the woman who we later learned is posing
as valkyrie who is actually a character
we've discussed on the show before more
of the enchantress from asgard
she uh tells she of this group of the
fancy pants yes
she tells them that she um wants to like
battle sexism in the world so she gets
gets the girls together to go fight
misogyny um and then at the end of it
like one male superhero's like i hope
you gals learned your lesson about
women's lib or something awful
and you're just like oh this was written
in in 1970 no they're just like
they they're like we'll come back again
if we have to keep defending feminism
but then they brought it back in 2008
and it made slightly more sense and it
was that she-hulk got the crap kicked
out of her by red hulk and wanted
revenge and so she assembles a team and
this team
is real valkyrie
thundra joins black widow susan richards
tigra helicat spider woman and storm so
there's a lot of x-men crossovers you
said hellcat right yes i thought i heard
you say hella cat
that's a better name
which would like she'd like wave her
tail around and fly i'm imagining stan
lee pitching it right now hella cat
it's okay i have to write an email okay
i have to write an email to marvel after
this about how hellcat should definitely
become helicat and grow little
helicopters on your head i'm very sorry
i interrupted you please go on no that's
totally fine um and apparently
no it might be the dumbest thing i've
ever said because i just said helicopter
but but that's so much better than
hellcat hellcat's fine but helicopter
just birthed the billion dollar
franchise steiner welcome to the one uh
hellcat purist in the comments who's
gonna like
is better than anything i've seen
something i always have to thank you two
for is taking my dumb dumb mistakes and
making them into a solid riff
you do this so often
i know it's dumb dumb mistakes this is
really
this is my wheelhouse oh man so anyway
it's a huge group of female years a lot
of people from um
you know who would like susan richards
and
storm would have to come in as part of
the the
assuming upcoming merge right of
everything coming back together so
obviously like the modern iteration
might be more difficult i mean we
she-hulk is coming soon um so it's again
not out of the question and i think the
rumor of the about the olivia wild movie
is that it is the spider woman movie
whatever she's doing for the vmc
still not confirmed yeah but um that is
the rumor is that olivia wilde's doing
the spider woman movie and so basically
this group subdues uh red hulk and they
defeat him and
they avenge she-hulk and and everybody
has a great time etc etc but the reason
the real reason i picked the lady
liberators is uh
look i love endgame you guys love
endgame we all love endgame but that
scene of all the women lining up was
nice and pandering in that it lasted for
eight to ten seconds and then it was
over it was it was rough stuff i did not
love it and i know that that's not a
feeling that i that i feel by myself in
the world um and i just would love to
see like especially because i feel like
you know
there hasn't been like a truly truly
awesome kind of female-led outing in the
mcu just yet and i feel like when you
get people like tatiana maslany and
tessa thompson and if florence pew takes
over the black widow role like her
this could be a really fun group of
actresses to play around with yeah and i
just think it could be a great time
based on who's already cast as these
people yeah i i think i think that
there's going to be
you know i love the expanded role that
wasp had in ant-man and the wasp yeah
yeah i liked a lot of parts of captain
marvel and i'm really looking forward to
the sequel i am too yeah i think i think
i think it's i think it's gonna be
really fun would have been a lot better
but yeah i like the character a lot and
i yeah i think that you know then we've
got the miss marvel show that's coming
right
the aforementioned kate bishop hawkeye
who it right he's already
a lot more excited
yeah and and again we have the
aforementioned she-hulk with her own
show yeah exactly and so you know we
have a lot happening and i liked
parts of captain marvel too but the only
thing about captain marvel as a female
superhero is she's
she's such a like
she's such a deus ex machina right she
shows up and she is like always all
powerful right and that's it and it
doesn't
it's i think it's more interesting to
you know the the avengers got the
stuffing kicked out of them regularly
and that was like that's part of the
tension that's part of the fun of a
superhero movie and i think it could be
great to watch a group of female
superheroes like really claw their way
and you know into a battle and
reign supreme yeah i think it could be
really cool bring back jessica jones
bring her back oh my god i loved her
yeah so there's but
have her play the character from don't
trust the being apartment 23.
yeah merge the two yeah yeah
yeah yeah we should see if disney owns
the rights to that show
i believe that they do
very good uh cool yeah that's i think
that's a great pick and i think that you
know so if if they could get some
version of that and make it not
feel like a focused grouped pandering
eight-second shot from a bigger movie
yeah i would like the opposite of the
thing that happened in endgame but its
own movie yeah right yeah yeah yeah i
love it
me too all right thanks no now tom what
is uh a marvel team that you'd like to
see in the mcu what can you bring to the
table here today i don't think you have
much to bring to the table but maybe tom
is always so unprepared for these chats
it's so ridiculous yeah i'm a simple man
with a simple mind
i don't believe that
i don't know art
but i know what i like and guys what i
want to talk about is is ecstatics uh
brian i i think maybe you've
you know a little bit about it nina
wasn't sure if you if you did or not
nope i'm just gonna buckle up and enjoy
the ride well let's go on a ride then
okay uh yeah
i take you now to the year 1991.
nina you're
a bouncing baby girl
yeah i've won
brian you have just received your first
copy of aarp magazine
brian no longer has to pay to ride the
public bus
and his moons over my hammy cost a mere
75 cents on the
dollar they were good times
and one of the biggest comic books in
the world is x-force it was created by
rob liefeld it is uh the militaristic
uh extension of the x-men it's x-men but
with the
pathogens
yeah the they're basically the x-men but
bad guys but still calling themselves
good guys they get to kill a lot of
people you get lots of classic
characters you get cable you get domino
you get the shatter star only of course
it's 1991 and it's it's rob liefeld so
they're all extreme and uh
it's one of the most successful comics
of the time because it's exactly what
everybody wants it's giant muscles and
teeny tiny girl waists and pouches on
pouches and the series goes on and it
keeps being extreme and time passes
the days turn into months and months
into years
ten years go by
the hertz rent-a-car company changes
celebrity spokespeople
good reason
[Laughter]
and in 2001 uh they're still doing their
thing
they're still in x-force uh it's a
slightly
different group of people but like uh
they're all still doing it they're still
very extreme only of course it's 2001 so
now they're all wearing black leather
and
[Laughter]
115 issues of this of this comic go on
telling the same continuous story and
then just kind of out of nowhere they
all disappear and they bring in
with issue 116 they bring in like a
whole new
team with a completely different
vibe like this this kind of like a pop
art look to it it's written by a new
writer named peter milligan and it's
it's being drawn by uh
mike allred who does this this terrific
kind of semi-jack kirby art style and
they bring in all of these new
characters that you have never heard of
before uh they're fantastic there's this
guy named zeitgeist who at 13 years old
now 14 years old finds out that his
vomit can melt people's flesh when he uh
gets drunk at a party and and starts to
make out with a girl and then
accidentally
takes her face off and then uh
there's this dude battering ram who's
you know your classic like
muscle guy he's the the smashes through
stuff he's very concerned about his
place on the team you have got uh this
gin genie who can create seismic
waves as long as she's drunk they're all
kind of trash cans is the cool thing
they are that's not my new halloween
[Laughter]
their reality tv show stars is their
thing they go out and they slaughter
people wholesale on pay-per-view
television and they are famous for being
famous and for killing people and it's
this
stunning indictment of the comic book
industry and what superheroes have
become and celebrity culture and
everything there are all of these fanta
there's uh plasm who's a uh kind of like
half liquid half gas melty man there's
the uh the frenchman who controls dark
energy there is of course everybody's
favorite
he's got face things that's his power uh
that's how they describe it
he's got face things
[Music]
like this fantastic new weird colorful
team uh that nina i thought
you would get a kick out of i they're a
lot of fun
i need this movie injected in my veins
at the next possible opportunity i need
it to come out tomorrow is it already
done
i think it could be a lot of fun
uh i especially like i i love slug i
don't know if you love i i love i mean
i'm looking at sluck and i look how do
you not love how do you not love a face
like that
that's what i'm saying and that's what
makes it like so difficult
uh when they they kill him three
pages into the first story
[Laughter]
poor slug
and then everybody else so everybody on
the team is dead by the end of the first
issue except for
two characters uh and uh
and the cameraman for the group a guy
named dupe who's just like a jelly bean
that floats around speaking aliens speak
all the time it is
the grossest weirdest comic book i i
loved the story so much every issue was
like this they would bring in new
characters and you never knew who was
going to make it to the next story who's
going to be an ongoing character
from a historical perspective it's also
fascinating because it changed the way
the marvel comics made stories uh
at this point in history up uh until now
like ever since 1954 there was this
thing called the comics code authority
which was uh the comic book industry's
way of self-regulating and making sure
that the government didn't come in and
like put ratings on stuff and uh they
had to send all of their stories to an
objective third party theoretically that
was going to stamp them with approval
and say this isn't too violent and
batman and robin aren't going to do
kissing so everything's going to be fine
and uh
that's all true
and in 2001 they sent the first issue of
this new team of uh of experts they sent
they sent this new team of x-force
members uh to the comic code authority
and they got back a message that said
yeah this this isn't okay
it's horrifying
and marvel said for the first time in
almost 50 years
and they printed it anyway and they
didn't care and uh
that was sort of the last nail in the
coffin for the comics code authority it
would like it would keep existing a
little bit for another 10 years but by
2011 like the last game in town had
stopped looking for these people's
approval and people were
just kind of telling whatever stories
they wanted to tell because most i think
that's fascinating comic books most of
the people who write comic books are
people our age instead of actual
children right
which is its own issue in some ways
but here we are here we are yeah
they've done something right yes yeah
okay
anyway chef's kiss perfect no notes 10
out of 10. terrific team
yes i would love to see this especially
if they did the same thing if they just
didn't care about this
tom who is your dream director
for this movie
um oh man
like who wouldn't maybe edgar wright i
was just thinking you're right yeah yeah
but he was like
if you get that
hot fuzz
yeah well i could i could see it
i could see it i mean since since it's
a lot of the book is you know is
predicated on that first issue going the
way it goes right you introduce all
these characters and then they all die
by the end
it seems more like it might make a
really good
show for a movie necessarily since
obviously disney plus is doing the mcu
shows now i could see it happening and
now with the the merger you're open all
these x characters that you weren't
before so well if it's a show i want to
propose um the always sunny creative
team i want to propose glenn howerton
rob mcelhenny and charlie day
that could get so gross they'd get so
weird with it yeah once charlie charlie
day is done voicing luigi
and voice uh why did you remind me of
that i was having a good day
i hope he's not done voicing luigi
not to get too far off topic
but chris pratt chris pratt is star-lord
so it's not too far off
yeah i think this movie might be a
little bit more interesting than people
are going to give it credit for because
this cast is insane
legitimately insane okay sorry i've
derailed us yet again i apologize
do you guys just want to do a quick
mario episode while we're here
can i just dream mario casting the super
mario brothers movie that we already
have is wonderful and i think not enough
people think it's great because my man
we've already thought about this
it's really good it's a really good good
movie and i think people need to give
another chance
uh
anyway that's all i have to say i feel
like we we've done a a poor job of
finding an ending for this episode
or at least i've done a poor job as the
ostensible person in charge
uh
sorry do you want to just get a shot or
a faces melt off i mean like it worked
for what's that tom what was that what
was the thing-faced character name
splurk
sparks block
i was [ __ ]
i wasn't that far off yeah so just shout
slug and the episode's over
is that how we should end the episode
probably spluck
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
video
[Music]